the universe today is happy and healthy
with exciting things going on but at
some point the night will turn dark
everything that once was Will peacefully
sleep
forever but what is the last thing that
will ever happen and when will it be it
turns out there is such a thing and you
probably haven't heard about it let's
travel to the end of the universe and
look at the last thing
after a messy birth our universe was a
sleepy baby warm and dark filled with
swirling clouds of hot hydrogen and
helium the story of creation is a story
of this gas and where it will end up
shortly after the universe got busy
making the first generation of stars
they were massive and lived violent
lives forging new elements only to
release most of them when they blew up
countless stars were born and refined
the gas available in the universe cycl
matter around each generation giving
most of its gas and fresh elements to
the next but not all gas is returned
every time a new generation of stars
forms they also make more and more red
dwarfs that burn slowly and live for
trillions of years when they die they
don't give their gas back to the
universe but turn into white dwarfs so
red dwarfs lock up more gas forever some
more gas is locked forever in other
remains of dead stars neutron stars and
black hole
which is bad as it reduces the material
available for new stars today the
universe is a great home for us and will
remain so for billions of years but most
of the gas has been used up or trapped
over 90% of the stars that will ever be
born have been born already to get to
the last thing to ever happen all other
things need to happen
first the next few hundred billion years
will be fun and a great time for
Galactic
exploration but step by step large stars
and stars like our sun will die out
eventually almost all the stars will be
red dwarves slowly dying the end of
everything but not quite in a few
trillion years the cosmic gas will
finally have run out about 88% of the
mass of every Galaxy will be white
dwarfs 2% neutron stars and black holes
and about 10% gas giants and sad brown
dwarf losers white dwarves are the
corpses of old Stars not much bigger
than Earth but on average as massive as
half our sun some even much more this
makes them the third densest objects in
the universe after neutron stars and
black holes about a million times denser
than the sun today since they used to be
active Stars their surface can be as hot
as 150,000 de white dwarfs are dim hot
dense spheres that don't do anything
anymore but eventually even white dwarfs
will die because they're slowly losing
their heat it takes at least 10 trillion
years more than 700 times longer than
the current age of the universe as they
do their cooling down the universe
around them will irreversibly grow dark
as more and more white dwarves burn out
and turn into dead husks black dwarves
spheres of death as cold as space itself
invisible against the dark backdrop over
trillions and trillions of years every
object in every Galaxy is eventually
either ejected into the void or its
orbit decays and it will fall into the
central black hole and be destroyed in
about a quintilian years all Galaxies
have evaporated and every object is on
its own in the center of its own
observable universe emptiness as far as
can be seen in any direction traveling
through black nothingness still there
are things that will happen black holes
are dying slowly they'll fizzle Away by
emitting Hawking radiation until they're
so small that they die in a final flash
of light light this will take about a
goog old years 10 to the power of 100
years until the last super massive black
hole dies a number so absurd there's
nothing to compare it to maybe some
living beings could have survived around
black holes but even this science
fiction option ends now after this
unsettling amount of time we're not even
close to the end now is the time of the
black dwarfs it turns out there's some
weird physics going on inside the dead
husk of stars the weird physics of black
dwarfs a black dwarf is a sphere the
size of Earth as massive as a star but
almost as cold as absolute zero Stars
stay alive because of their intense heat
in their course so why do black dwarves
not collapse into a black hole what
keeps them together deep inside a black
dwarf matter is squeezed to densities
millions of times greater than anything
we see on Earth the pressure is so great
that electrons can't combine with the
nuclei to form atoms instead matter is
weird togenerate the nuclei are
compressed by the weight of the star
locked into a rigid latice while the
electrons form a plasma between them and
these electrons hold the star together
we're simplifying but imagine matter as
a subway train and electrons as
passengers if there are empty seats
passengers spread out because they care
a lot about their personal space But as
a black dwarf is so incredibly dense
this is like squishing more and more
passengers into our train gravity is
pushing in trying to collapse it the
passengers are forced to sit and stand
close together which they hate and so
the passengers our electrons try to push
out Against Gravity as hard as they can
this way the electrons that are having a
horrible time in the crowded Train
That's the black dwarf hold up the star
everything else in the universe may have
crumbled already but these tiny
particles push against each other until
the end of time or they would if quantum
mechanics didn't ruin everything simp
simplifying a lot when particles get
close enough sometimes they can jump at
each other and fuse together a process
called Quantum tunneling this happens
constantly in stars because of their
intense heat it's one of the key reasons
Stars confuse elements into new ones but
it also happens at a temperature near
absolute zero just well mind's numbingly
slowly this is the final step to
creating the last interesting thing to
ever happen in our universe here in this
black dwarf something fantastic occurs
nothing happens for a trillion years
nothing at all can you imagine that but
then a single fusion reaction two carbon
nuclei combined by Quantum tunneling to
become magnesium another 100 trillion
years pass it happens again then nothing
for another bazillion years oh two
oxygen nuclei combine into silicon as
eons pass the nuclei in the Frozen black
black dwarf slowly combine making new
heavier nuclei and these take even
longer to fuse but given enough time
they eventually will remember the
breathtaking amount of time it took for
a super massive black hole to evaporate
that's a brief moment in comparison to
what's going on here the difference
between a second and trillions of years
has lost all meaning over a time so
absurd that it has no name nuclei keep
fusing into heavier elements until when
silicon nucle fuse they form nickel 56
nickel 56 is radioactive which means
it's unstable and when it eventually
decays and turns into ion it emits two
positrons antimatter electrons and these
two positrons find two electrons and
annihilate them and themselves which is
a problem remember how the uncomfortable
electrons produce the pressure to hold
the star together destroying the
electron means fewer friends to help
them hold up the star losing an electron
does not give them more space to scratch
their butts it just makes gravity
squeeze harder the walls closing in on
those that remain in the case of the
most massive black dwarfs this is
catastrophic bit by bit the black dwarf
turns into a sphere of iron and more
electrons are
annihilated for at least 10 to the power
of 1,000 years almost but not quite
forever there's no visible change in the
entire universe and then finally the
last thing to ever happen happens the
black dwarf has lost one too many
electrons it can no longer support its
immense mass and goes into an
uncontrolled collapse a supernova it
first implodes and then explodes as
bright as a Galaxy and fills the empty
Universe with light again a beautiful
moment nobody will get to enjoy and then
as quickly as it began it's all over
Darkness again
emptiness that was the last thing that
will ever happen happen the universe may
now be truly dead but don't be bummed
out about it this is so far away in the
future that forever hardly describes it
today the universe is the best place it
could be for us and you can sleep tight
tonight knowing the last interesting
thing that will ever happen is forever
long
away for now there are still plenty of
interesting things to discover and the
younger you start discovering the more
you'll understand about the world we
live in our sponsor kbo helps kids get a
head start there with a range of unique
crates on a myriad of stem topics
covering science technology engineering
arts and maths every crate is like a
little Adventure in a box imagine the
excitement of a trip to the museum or an
amazing theme park but delivered to your
doorstep with everything you need neatly
packed inside there are different lines
designed for kids of all ages and
interests so there's something for
everyone like us kiwo spends a
ridiculous amount of time on fine-tuning
each crate every one of their 2,000
available projects took more than 1,000
hours to develop by experts and is
tested by kids we really liked the Kiwi
C Tinker crate line which gives you a
Hands-On engineering project with all of
the educational and instructional
information you need to complete the
project at home we might also have
decided to just keep some of them around
the office and not hand the extras to
any kids we know if you want to try out
kiwi Co and get the best deal click on
the link in the info box or use the code
KS gazal to get 50% off your first month
or if you want to try it out first they
also offer individual crates in the Kiwi
Co store at kts Gant we love to spark
curiosity and we love to work with
companies that share this
[Music]
goal
for